dan bongino uh finally joined us dan you
gave us a finger you
went like this for a second yeah it
really hurt our feelings i don't know
what you do on your show but for us we
hope to see the people
the finger i gave you is important
though you have to be very it wasn't the
middle one
number one
like right as i was about to go on the
air the whole wireless system in my
studio here
crapped out so i had to call you guys on
my cell phone old school but i've got
right after we did this on ransomware
and russia
right there we go dan you've got to go
you watch that back it was really funny
right so you guys i i can't believe we
were talking behind you over the air
i know i just didn't want you to start
talking to me and i didn't hear that
would have been even worse
so i had to give you the hold finger so
dan what do you think of brat
and his comments well you know i worked
under chief bratton he's an amazing guy
and he was one of the guys who started
the whole broken window style of
policing
where he had this bold and i'm not being
sarcastic
because back then it was a bald idea
where he said hey
maybe we should start enforcing you know
low-level crimes
people who commit low-level crimes right
you know are usually the guys who go on
to commit
bigger crimes in other words turnstile
jumpers usually go on the train and
commit muggings
so if we arrest them uh for that for
jumping the turnstile the broken windows
policing
will probably lower the crime rate that
happened and he's right this war on cops
you know i'm going to talk about this
today on my
on my podcast and my radio show which
you can watch on fox nation
yeah great plug there and let me just
throw that in there but there are three
big huge threats to america right now
critical race theory
uh china and the war on cops i mean once
you get americans to hate each
other for all kinds of superficial
characteristics like race and you create
the chaos
the best way to allow the chaos to
continue to brew
is to engage in a war on cops and stop
them from enforcing the law
and it's it's really a disgrace i mean
liberalism is a forest fire right now
destroying america piece by piece and we
can't let it continue
right so dan uh uh by the way we uh
i did give you a brilliant introduction
you just didn't hear it uh well no i did
in fact plug your show
but i do have something else to go back
on let's look back at what
the dan bondino show over the weekend
your uh debut was sensational
and you had a chance to talk to one guy
in particular
uh it was uh jaco willanik and
if you want to see that go online that's
when ainsley is waving me off i'm just
saying we don't
we were going to play a sound bite but
because of the mishap i think we don't
yeah
we're out of time wait a second no way
ainsley can you can you bring it put it
on now
all right we got it we got it he's so
wonderful former navy seal you're good
friends with him
we've interviewed him a lot he is so
strong and he talks about
what makes america great listen to this
we can we can call it whatever you want
to call it you can paint it you can put
lipstick on it
but the nature of war is death the
nature of war is killing people
it's it ends up in close combat it's
hard you carry a lot of weight you carry
your friends
you were talking about uh this idea
around critical race theory
we can tell you what i learned in the
military that's critical about race that
is
we don't care what we want is we want to
look out for each other
we know that it's critical that we focus
on what our job is that's the most
important thing and that's what you need
to stay focused on in
that job that's what's critical
about race that's interesting dan
well thank you everyone who watched
saturday night 10 p.m
please uh watch it again i deeply
appreciate all your feedback
jocko was amazing um i had another guest
on former obama administration official
roger fisk and
you know i asked him about critical race
theory which indicates pretty clearly if
you're white you should be judged as
being white not on your character
and it says you're an oppressor so i
asked him a simple question
i wasn't being a jerk i was a simple are
you an oppressor
and he seemed taken aback by the
question why would you be taking it back
if you believe in critical race theory
you believe you're an oppressor so
i encourage everyone to watch it in the
interview with giaco was great and ron
desantis
uh strikes again he just went after it
on the interview as well he's going to
be taken on critical race theory in
florida which we uh which we really
really love all right dan thank you very
much
we'll see you next time bye bye i hope
thanks guys
[Music]